hey everybody Darren Criss here saying
hello to you from the comfort of my home
to yours hopefully you're safe and snug
wherever you are staying healthy
I've always want to do one of these
things with BuzzFeed and I always get to
see people that I admire do funny
quizzes and stuff like that I am here to
take a quiz to find out which Ryan
Murphy character are you you being me
Darren let's find out if your life were
a TV show what genre would it be horror
supernatural musical drama comedy or
romance I would like to think that it's
all of the above but just for some
giggles I feel like we should give the
people what they want I would probably
say it's a musical cuz musicals are
inherently a comedy so let's just all
not all the time but I guess
stereotypically so let's let's go with
that choose an iconic guest star from
the Ryan Murphy Cinematic Universe Kate
Hudson who was on Glee with us Lady gaga
who was an American Horror Story hotel
Nick Jonas Nicky Jay was in scream
queens I think he was a frat boy uh
Naomi Campbell less am I am I am I
allowed to say that I don't think I am I
think she she she blesses me she chooses
max Greenfield who kicked ass on the
assassination of John watch E and then
Britney Spears who was on Glee on an
episode that I wasn't on by the time I
joined the show they had all these
amazing guest stars that I didn't get to
get to mean I don't know when the next
time I would see Naomi Campbell in a
musical so for the sheer novelty of that
I'm just gonna click on Amy Campbell
because I just really want to see where
this where there's Rabideau leads you're
walking down the street and feel the
urge to sing which song are you belting
and this is all the time teenage Juma
Katy Perry
very good chance I do that I love that
song despite the fact I did a ton on the
show Glee I still think that song rules
blackbird who built sout blackbird
that's a very bold choice to be belting
I think it's really a like a belt song
everybody wants to rule the world Tears
for Fears that's good one don't stop me
now by Queen oh that's a really good
hero this is a good one by David Bowie
hey soul sister if I'm at my bar I'm on
the piano I will play don't stop me now
by Queen however because I am walking
down the street and it's kind of a
walking down the street soundtrack song
I will say everybody wants to rule the
world now pick another fabulous
character from the ryan murphy cinematic
universe
I'm just picking somebody we got Rachel
Berry from Glee
pray tell from pose dr. Brock Holtz
scream queens
we got Donovan from from Aaron art or
story to tell Marie Laveau the
incomparable Angela Bassett from
American American horse story coven and
of course the very talented mr. young
Ben Platt from the politician Angela you
know this if you'll ever see this you
know you have the key to my heart I'm
gone with miss Bassett any excuse to
hang out with her is a good time I think
is a picture somewhere of me playing a
piano with her sitting on the piano with
a rose in her mouth
that actually happened in New York City
one night adventures from Broadway that
is a thing that happened in my life and
I gladly squeeze it into every
conversation that I can just like now
she's an old Hollywood film to watch we
got Casablanca Breakfast at Tiffany's
Citizen Kane It Happened One Night
singing in the rain and whatever
happened to Baby Jane all very different
movies I'll say I'll say Casablanca I
know this is supposed to be a thing
that's really indicative of like Who I
am but at this point I'm just I'm
playing mind games with myself because I
just want to see where this leads
now choose a Ryan Murphy project to
watch this is good cuz I haven't seen a
lot of I haven't seen a significant
amount of Glee there's a huge chunk of
Glee I just never saw that I don't know
when I'm gonna get around to because
with all the two shows to watch one ago
you know what I'll watch the show I
spent years on okay the new normal
nip/tuck Eat Pray Love normal heart Feud
pose okay well I have seen it a number
of these I'll say nip/tuck because I I
only know a few episodes and that was
really you know it was a big show so
I'll say nip/tuck okay finally how would
your friends describe me determined
radiant charming misunderstood
multifaceted or fabulous gosh it depends
what time of night it is drinks are in
vaults some of my friends would be that
articulate I would hope they say that
I'm fabulous
that's the I want Angela Bassett Buddha
lady and they only Campbell icon to hear
about me haha
I got Camille who plays it was the
character who plays my characters
girlfriends on the show Hollywood played
by the beautiful Laura hairier you got
Camille Washington from Hollywood you're
radiant can-do attitude makes people
like you
people like you and jealous of you but
you don't pay attention to the
negativity because you've got your eyes
on the prize and will work your tush off
until you get it damn Skippy I will I'm
not paying attention to haters haters
gon hate as I think the modern parlance
would would would tell you and yeah I
got my eyes on the prize I do like to
think it worked pretty hard this is a
poem the fact that I am back with my
longtime collaborator and friend Ryan
Murphy we have a show on Netflix called
Hollywood about 1940s Hollywood
hopefully you will have the time which I
know you just might to check out there
you have it thank you BuzzFeed for
leading me to the end of the rabbit hole
that I created for myself